>>> FORMER FBI DEPUTY DIRECTOR
McCABE WHO WAS FIRED IN 2018 BY
JEFF SESSIONS HAS SETTLED A
LAWSUIT WITH THE JUSTICE
DEPARTMENT GETTING HIS JOB BACK,
HIS PENSION, BACK PAY, SO HE CAN
RETIRE WITH ALL THOSE BENEFITS.
THE SETTLEMENT RESOLVES A
LAWSUIT FILED BY McCABE WHO
ARGUED HIS OUSTER WAS THE RESULT
OF A VENDETTA DRIVEN BY THE
FORMER PRESIDENT.
HE WAS FIRED THREE YEARS AGO
JUST HOURS BEFORE A PLANNED
RETIREMENT.
THE INSPECTOR GENERAL SAID HE
LIED REPEATEDLY ABOUT HILLARY
CLINTON.
THE CASE WAS REFERRED TO
PRESIFEDERAL
PROSECUTORS WHO DECIDED NO T TO
PURSUE CHARGES AND EVER SINCE,
THE FORMER PRESIDENT HAS
CONTINUED TO ATTACK HIM.
HERE'S ONE OF THOSE MOMENTS IN
2019.
>> I THINK McCABE HAS MADE A
FOOL OUT OF HIMSELF OVER THE
LAST COUPLE OF DAYS AND HE
REALLY LOOKS TO ME LIKE SORT OF
A POOR MAN'S J. EDGAR HOOVER.
I THINK HE'S A DISASTER AND WHAT
HE WAS TRYING TO DO WAS TERRIBLE
AND HE WAS CAUGHT.
I'M VERY PROUD TO SAY WE CAUGHT
HIM SO WE'LL SEE WHAT HAPPENS,
BUT HE IS A DISGRACED MAN.
HE WAS TERMINATED, NOT BY ME.
HE WAS TERMINATED BY OTHERS.
THE IG REPORT WAS A DISASTER.
A DISASTER FROM HIS STANDPOINT.
ANYBODY READING THE IG REPORT
WOULD SAY HOW COULD A MAN LIKE
THIS BE INVOLVED WITH THE FBI?
AND THE FBI HAS SOME OF THE
GREATEST PEOPLE.
SOME OF THE FINEST PEOPLE YOU'LL
EVER MEET.
BUT THIS MAN IS A COMPLETE
DISASTER.
>> THE IRONY OF COURSE IS THAT
THE FORMER PRESIDENT IS NOW THE
DISASTER AND THE DISGRACED
PERSON.
ANDREW McCABE JOINS US, CNN'S
SENIOR LAW ENFORCEMENT ANALYST.
FIRST INTERVIEW SINCE THE
SETTLEMENT WAS REACHED.
FIRST OF ALL, WHAT DOES THIS
MEAN FOR YOUR AND YOUR FAMILY?
>> OH, MY GOSH.
ANDERSON, I CAN'T TELL YOU WHAT
THIS HAS BEEN LIKE GOING
THROUGH.
WHAT THIS WHOLE CAMPAIGN HAS PUT
MY WIFE THROUGH.
MY CHILDREN.
MY PARENTS.
SO TO HAVE A SETTLEMENT OF THIS
LAWSUIT AND ONE THAT SO CLEARLY
INDICATES THIS SHOULD NEVER HAVE
HAPPENED, IT IS BOTH AN
INCREDIBLE RELIEF.
IT'S SATISFYING, BUT IT'S ALSO,
YOU KNOW, IT'S ALSO KIND OF SAD.
I MEAN, LIKE, THIS SHOULD NEVER
HAVE HAPPEN.
MY FAMILY SHOULD HAVE NEVER HAD
TO GO THROUGH THIS.
>> I NEVER REALIZED I THINK IT
WAS ON A FRIDAY NIGHT, YOU HAD
HAD A MEAL WITH YOUR FAMILY
ESSENTIALLY RETIREMENT
CELEBRATION WITH YOUR FAMILY
BECAUSE YOU WERE RETIRING THE
NEXT DAY.
AND THEY, THEY FIRED YOU RIGHT
BEFORE THAT CONSCIOUSLY.
YOU KNOW, VINDICTIVELY.
WHAT WAS IT LIKE TO HAVE THE
FORMER PRESIDENT WHO DOESN'T
KNOW YOU.
HE HAS NO IDEA, ANYTHING ABOUT
YOU, JUST PICK YOU OUT OF, YOU
KNOW, OBSCURITY, ESSENTIALLY, IN
TERMS OF HIS KNOWLEDGE OF YOU,
AND JUST FOCUS ON YOU?
AND ATTACK YOU?
>> IT WAS SO BIZARRE, ANDERSON.
YOU KNOW, ON DECEMBER 23rd OF
2017, HE TWEETED OUT TO THE
WORLD THAT HE WAS RACING ME TO
MY RETIREMENT.
I MEAN, TO KNOW THAT YOU
ESSENTIALLY HAVE A TARGET ON
YOUR BACK FROM THE MOST POWERFUL
PERSON IN THE WORLD.
THE PERSON YOU WORK FOR AS A
MEMBER OF THE EXECUTIVE BRANCH.
IT WAS LIKE UPSIDE DOWN WORLD.
LIKE, YOU CAN'T EVEN, I CAN'T
EVEN DESCRIBE HOW TERRIFYING AND
ANNOYING AND HUMILIATING THAT
IS.
BUT YOU KNOW, THAT'S, THAT'S
WHAT HE SUBJECTED PEOPLE THROUGH
FOR FOUR YEARS.
>> IT'S ALSO AFTER A LIFE OF
PUBLIC SERVICE.
THERE'S, I'M SURE A LOT OF
PEOPLE IN YOUR POSITION COULD
HAVE LONG AGO GONE TO A LAW FIRM
OR GONE TO DO OTHER WORK THAT
WOULD HAVE BEEN FAR MORE, YOU
KNOW, FBINANCIALLY REWARDING.
YOU WERE SERVING THE PUBLIC.
DOES YOUR SETTLEMENT WITH THE
JUSTICE DEPARTMENT ADMIT ANY
KIND OF POLITICAL INFLUENCE ON
THEIR PART OF YOUR FIRING?
BECAUSE IT WAS OBVIOUSLY JEFF
SESSIONS UNDER PRESSURE PUTTING
DOJ UNDER PRESSURE.
THE RIPPLE EFFECTS OF THAT.
>> ABSOLUTELY.
THIS WAS CLEARLY AN ACT OF
VINDICATION AGAINST A PERCEIVED
POLITICAL ENEMY, WHICH WASN'T
EVEN TRUE, BUT THAT'S WHAT THEY
DID.
THE PRESIDENT DEMANDED THIS AND
JEFF SESSIONS COMPLIED AND THE
REST OF THE DEPARTMENT OF
JUSTICE COMPLIED AS WELL.
INSPECTOR GENERAL DELIVERED A
TRUNCATED, RUSHED, UNFAIR REPORT
THAT LEFT OUT MATERIAL EVIDENCE.
THE FBI, KNOWING THEIR PROCESS,
WOULDN'T CONCLUDE BEFORE I
RETIRED, RUSHED IT, SPED UP THE
CLOCK TO GET DONE WHAT THE
ATTORNEY GENERAL AND THE
PRESIDENT WERE DEMANDING.
I MEAN, IT'S, THAT'S WHY THIS
SETTLEMENT, I MEAN, IT'S A GREAT
THING FOR MY FAMILY, BUT I THINK
IT'S A MESSAGE TO GOVERNMENT
EMPLOYEES, TO CIVIL SERVANTS
EVERYWHERE.
THIS IS THE CURRENT DEPARTMENT
OF JUSTICE STANDING UP FOR
FAIRNESS AND THE RULE OF LAW.
IN THE SETTLEMENT AGREEMENT
ITSELF, THEY AGREE THAT MEMBER
OF THE EXECUTIVE BRANCH SHOULD
NOT INTERFERE IN INTERNAL
POLITICAL, INTERNAL PERSONNEL
MATTERS BECAUSE IT CREATES THE
APPEARANCE OF POLITICAL
INFLUENCE.
>> THE JUSTIFICATION WAS THAT A
REPORT SAID YOU HAD LIED AT A
MEDIA LEAK TO INVESTIGATORS.
CAN YOU BRIEFLY EXPLAIN TO
PEOPLE NOT FAMILIAR WITH THE
CASE WHAT THAT WAS ABOUT?
>> SURE.
I WAS ASKED IN TWO DIFFERENT
INTERVIEWS ABOUT WHAT I KNEW
ABOUT A RELEASE OF INFORMATION
TO A JOURNALIST OF A STORY IN
OCTOBER OF 2016.
AND IN BOTH CASES, I MISSPOKE
AND THEN IMMEDIATELY AFTER
CORRECTED THE RECORD, REACHED
OUT TO THE FOLKS THAT I HAD
SPOKEN TO AND POINTED THEM IN
THE RIGHT DIRECTION.
TOLD THEM EXACTLY WHAT HAPPENED.
NEVER AT ANY TIME DID I MISLEAD
ANYONE ABOUT ANYTHING AND I
THINK THAT'S WHAT TODAY'S RESULT
FINALLY AFTER ALL THESE YEARS IS
SAYING THIS DAGAIN AND AGAIN AN
AGAIN.
I THINK THAT'S WHAT THIS RESULT
MAKES CLEAR.
>> IN FEBRUARY OF 2020, NEARLY
TWO YEARS AFTER THE
INVESTIGATION WAS OPEN,
PROSECUTORS DECLINED TO BRING
ANY CHARGES.
THAT'S 20 MONTHS TO THE DAY OF
THIS SETTLEMENT.
DID YOU EXPECT IT TO TAKE THAT
LONG?
>> OF COURSE NOT.
THE INSPECTOR GENERAL REFERS
REPORTS TO PROSECUTORS ALL THE
TIME.
THEY'RE TURNED AROUND IN DAYS
AND WEEKS.
THIS WENT ON FOR 20 MONTHS.
I PERSONALLY BELIEVE THAT IT WAS
NECESSARY.
IT WAS NECESSARY FOR THE
DEPARTMENT OF JUSTICE TO PURSUE
THIS VINDICTIVE, CRIMINAL
PROSECUTION TO VALIDATE WHAT
THEY HAD DONE WITH MY FIRING.
IT WAS AN EFFORT TO KEEP THE
STORY STRAIGHT.
TO KEEP PERPETUATING THIS MYTH.
INCREDIBLY DAMNING.
>> THE DAY IT WAS ANNOUNCED NO
CHARGES WOULD BE FILED GAGAINST
YOU, YOU SAID I DON'T THINK I'LL
EVER BE FREE OF THIS PRESIDENT
AND THIS MANIACAL RAGE HE'S
DIRECTED AT ME AND MY WIFE.
DO YOU FEEL FREE TODAY?
>> I MEAN, I FEEL BETTER, BUT I
DON'T FEEL FREE.
I DON'T KID MYSELF TO THINK THAT
THE PRESIDENT IS GOING TO PUT
ASIDE HIS HORRIFIC JUDGMENT, HIS
CONSTANT LYING AND HIS
TORMENTING OF ME AND MY FAMILY.
I'M SURE THIS WILL JUST ADD
ANOTHER LOG TO